de entregar esta credencial es oficial
pedro castillo asumirá la presidencia de
perú este 28 de julio el jurado nacional
de elecciones y su entrega de los
credenciales al maestro y a su
vicepresidenta dina baluarte los dejamos
para hacer un perú de cara al próximo
bicentenario un perú más semanas son más
más comprometido más humano
en ese marco debo decirles también que
estoy acá para cumplir este papel
muy importante muy comprometedor en el
marco de la gobernabilidad respetando la
institucionalidad respetando a esta
constitución dicho triunfo se dio a
conocer más de un mes después de la
segunda vuelta electoral y de
incertidumbre por quien dirigiría al
perú la contrincante de castillo keiko
fujimori denunció sin pruebas
fehacientes que hubo fraude en el
proceso e insistió en que se impugnen
actas pero falló en el intento y perdió
por tercera vez su oportunidad de
gobernar mientras tanto la polarización
se mantiene en esta nación donde los
oponentes al partido perú libre temen
las propuestas económicas y las
ideologías del presidente electo rechazó
rotundamente desde este espacio
donde acabo de recibir este mandato que
no vamos a distraernos en otras cosas
porque el perú es emergente y rechazó
rotundamente de que vamos a traer
algunos modelos de otros países no somos
chavistas
no somos comunistas no somos extremistas
- somos terroristas vamos a combatir el
terrorismo
venga de donde venga también los
congresistas electos juramentaron en una
ceremonia privada mientras el país
entero está a la espera de la lista de
ministros